hi everyone my name is Matt and today
i'm working with Psych2Go to bring
you this extremely informative video
today I'll be giving you some advice on
dating people with social anxiety for
all you extroverts out there and those of
you who have little to no problem
socializing as someone who deals with
social anxiety and anxiety in general on a
daily basis these tips are important to
build a relationship with someone who
has trouble socializing i will say this
advice is just from my perspective
everybody's different but I feel like I
have a pretty good grasp on what it
takes for people like me to form
successful relationships or even close
friendships without further ado let's
get into it first thing be
straightforward with them we're shy
people that's why they call it social
anxiety sure we may muster up the
courage to ask you out but I never know
what to do afterwards do i make a move
do i go in for the kiss like what what
do i do we need to date extroverts or
nothing's gonna freakin happen in the
relationship for example i dated a very
shy person someone even shyer then me
surprisingly and we ended up breaking up
because we never really communicated
their needs to be that one person in the
relationship that can initiate this
stuff at first did you hear that last
part at first
usually when a shy person gets to know
someone they were up to them and they
become a lot more extroverted with them
so the straightforward thing is the push
to get that ball rolling
second thing to take into consideration
we're not mind reader's what i mean by
this is if something is bothering you
tell us this kind of ties in with the
whole straightforward thing but bear
with me people with anxiety are the
biggest fans of conflict and nine out of
ten people want to know what the problem
is so they can resolve it in an ideal
relationship you get what you give so
communication especially about something
that's bothering you
it's a must and ignored problem doesn't
go away it just gets worse third thing
reinsurance is an amazing thing
look we all have our bad days with
people with anxiety and people like me
that juggle depression with that when it
rains it freakin pores what everyone
needs in the situation is reassurance
from their significant other
they need to know that their wanted
needed loved what have you
I mean of course they already know that
but it's nice to be reminded when you're
down the last piece of advice I have to
offer panic attacks happen
sometimes for no reason at all this goes
for your significant other your friends
your family etc just be aware that they
happen and it's not easy to get out of
them and it's even impossible to get
someone to stop having one
all you can do is hold them let them
know you're not going anywhere and just
wait it out
panic attacks are one of the scariest
things I've ever experienced and all you
can really do is just let it run its
course understanding that and just being
there for the person is all you really
need to do well i hope you guys learned
something from this but remember like in
any relationship you get what you put
into it nobody likes a selfish partner
if you have any tips that I might have
missed feel free to put them down in the
comments if you like staring at my face
for the duration maybe you consider
check out my channel it will be down in
the description and maybe an annotation
somewhere around here and make vlogs
talking about what's going on up here
or what I've recently done and I try to
add some humor to it when I can and for
what I'm feeling analytical I make game
reviews I had a great time talking to
you guys today and hopefully I'll see
you real soon have a great one